en numéro 3 on commence se poser au dvd
avec cette série date fixe dont tout le
monde parle entraînements ça s'appelle
squid games et m'a dit vous êtes tombe
la nuit je suis en plein dedans ne
sortez pas
c'est une série coréenne un carton
version audio caen corrigé à dori et
peut-être encore et non je n'en jg je
suis passé il ouvert est cool c'est
devant la cour est devant la corée oui
je peux ses doigts courent et moi de
passer de regarder comment comment on
fait pour passer 2 valentin gies est au
dessus comme ça jamais vous aviez où
j'étais tranquillement [ __ ] au genou
n'est pas possible ce week-end à parler
à l'occasion de la sortie de cette série
n'a pu organiser un grand événement
surprise et la plateforme invité les
fans de la série à venir jouer les fans
avaient rendez vous rue d'alexandrie
l'attaquant des ticos françois après ça
s'est passé comme prévu puisque ce qui
est curieux que ça c'est pétain ouais
bah une bagarre généralisée ah ouais et
général ouais un truc de fou regardez
cette vidéo date à qui alors sachez que
ça c'est le phénomène du moment vous
fait découvrir défaut de senna dans
touche pas à mon poste c'est le truc du
moment non mais je vous dis ouais voilà
la série 15 à des appels tout ça c'est
une folie mondiale oui je sais le
mondial famille pourquoi vous êtes
énervé
[Rires]
[Musique]
on pensait qu'on ne pouvait pas faire
mieux que plus belle la vie et pourtant
netflix est en train de tout casser sur
le marché de la fiction avec sa nouvelle
série squid games une création
sud-coréenne un peu flippante
refuse de jouer il sera mes limites la
série raconte donc le parcours de 456
candidats faucher qui doit faire des
jeux enfantins comme un deux trois
soleil par exemple pour gagner de
l'argent beaucoup d'argent mais le petit
hic c'est que s'ils perdent ils meurent
en foutant du sang partout
il fallait pas plus d'enjeu pour que les
gens adorent le concept et surtout les
jeunes qui se ruent en masse sur le
programme pourtant déconseillé aux moins
de 18 ans du coup note ficc surf sur la
vague pour recréer des éléments de la
série en tout genre comme cette poupée 1
2 3 soleil à manille qui vous repère si
vous traversez au rouge
[Musique]
ou sept salles de jeu éphémère à paris
qui a ouvert ce week-end vous pouviez
refaire des épreuves du jeu du coup pas
tous les ados se sont ruées sur le lieu
provoquant des files d'attentes
interminables
et forcément quand certains ont tenté
d'en dépasser d'autres ça a posé des
petits soucis d'organes
presse la police est venue mettre un
terme à l'événement et si finalement on
n'était pas mieux avec plus belle la vie
non un bon ok dommage
[Musique]
ouais alors et non mais c'est un truc de
ouf franchement gilles verdez alors la
série mais ils ont quand même un tout
petit peu organisé la bagarre ils
savaient très bien que l'entrée était
extrêmement réduite peu de gens
pouvaient entrer au bout de cinq heures
ça s'est énervé je trouve que pour faire
le buzz c'était un peu au détriment des
passionnés de mon avis pas regarder les
remèdes attendre mais moi je comprends
pas l'engouement pour cette série pour
moi c'est un plus pas le copier une pâle
copie de kazan et papel version coréenne
en plus une série qui encouragent la
violence et la série vous faut pas
s'étonner qu'ils aient des bastons après
et le budget moyen de chocs ces 20
millions d'euros soit trois fois plus
qu'une fiction télé pour moi c'est que
de la forme n'y a aucun fond je suis
dépassé 20 millions d'euros par épisode
imminente 3 par épisode 20 millions
d'euros pour le tout c'est énorme alors
oui je suis pas d'accord c'est quand
même très haute à un concept
exceptionnel dans l'hypothèse que tu
peux c'est tout un concept c'est quoi le
concept le concept en fait c'est des
gens qui sont fauchés qui se retrouvent
réunis tous les ans avec les autres dans
un endroit assez spécial avec tes des
univers qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
on voit justement qu'il ya beaucoup
d'argent qui a été mis parce que c'est
vraiment que des gens voilà édition et
qui se sont butés au but c'est un jeu
d'enfant ils voient des jeux d'enfants
donc au fur et à mesure on leur
distribue de la nourriture des fois pour
les affamés des fois pour les élèves
parce que comme moi
[Rires]
lorsque vous perdez au jeu vous êtes
directement éliminé
on en reparlera en tout cas merci kelly
tout à fait sûr résumé voilà je savais
pas mais je vais commencer à regarder ce
que j'ai un compte netflix
la deuxième position du podium des
médias on retrouve ce cortège de mariage
qu'on parlait un cortège qui a provoqué
une énorme pagaille sur une route
nationale vendredi dernier le cortège
s'est arrêté en pleine voie et pas des
participants sont descendus de voiture
sachez que c'était le mariage du sud
isabelle
où on a les images regardez
on se souvenait de vienne sont qui avait
bloqué une autoroute en 2017 pour
tourner le clip d'une jolie petite
comptine de noël
sauf que les routes va là bas c'est fait
pour rouler un et pas pour créer des
bouchons qui rendent fous les gens
franchement c'est abusé cette situation
mais apparemment tout le monde n'est pas
de cet avis à bron en banlieue lyonnaise
dans l'agglomération lyonnaise un
cortège de mariage à semer la pagaille
il s'est arrêté en pleine voie sur une
nationale bref roman d or nous en a
parlé toute la matinée de ce blocage et
à l'entendre on a l'impression qu'il
nous décrit limite le garage de
guillaume genton qui avait des voitures
de luxe une quinzaine de véhicules et de
berlines des voitures qui coûtent des
centaines de milliers d'euros une
ferrari et un autre mariage avait déjà
causé ce même souci dans le val d'oise
la semaine dernière des scènes de
violence en pleine rue pour un mariage
du coup on espère juste que le jour où
gilles et fatou se diront enfin oui ce
sera un peu plus calme
ce sont les médias qui est préparé par
nos équipes qui vont au travail sa bio
vous avez vu cette histoire c'est
incroyable
depuis 2012 il ya plusieurs villes
maintenant dont nice notamment
argenteuil je crois aussi ils font
signer maintenant aux futurs mariés une
sorte de charte ma déontologie avec des
choses qu'ils n'ont plus le droit de
faire pas le droit de faire ils
s'engagent à les respecter sinon on peut
carrément annuler le mariage voir le
repousser et c'est donc donc là
normalement ils peuvent sans courant
courir non mais c'est vrai bloqué
resserrer les rangs et à garder sur
mariage j'ai pensé mais mariage mais
n'ont jamais jamais jamais passé avait
fait quoique food on veut 22 avoir
commencé comme
un beau mariage alors le mariage de plus
le plus onéreux voulait ouais sauf a dit
sandra oui c'est vrai ah oui alors que
tf1 n'a pas pu non non non c'est c'est
le magazine un magazine qui a payé
longtemps rêvé bien sûr pari un peu fou
auquel à 90% à payer alors alors alors
ce magazine a fait faillite depuis en
plus c'est vrai c'était pas ou de france
comme ça voilà d'accord on l'avait vendu
l'exclusivité combien j'ai tout vous
dire comme d'habitude comme ça j'aurai
des tweets incendiaires mais de 900000
euros
alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que
j'avais j'avais tout tout tout investi
dans my j'avais gardé pour moi bien
évidemment et mais c'était un trait au
mariage
c'était fou et toupet kabassan cette
allure sinon j'aime bien je me de
bénéfice au mariage mon nom est plus
cher que ça avait il y avait 500
personnes ouais le mariage était fou il
y avait tout le paf à ce mariage mais
quand je vous dis tout ça il y avait 80
patron de m6 toutes les stars ça c'est
vedette de télévision web était témoin
les rues c'est fou non il était valérie
donc la partie oui voyez j'ai pas été là
bas circoncision du petit mais j'étais
omar
el mahdi avait pas bénin email mahelma
les gens
n'ont pas dit non il y avait 15 avec une
qu'une denis paradis avec gad elmaleh
c'est tout
on était donc se marier et hommes
s'apprécient un show c'est pas un
mariage et non cessible c'est con mais
là il sait que 900 mille aussi le
mariage non parce que mon fils a des
goûts simples quelqu'un quelqu'un payer
le mariage de loti chasse et pêche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant personne n'a payé personne
n'a osé lauriers on s'y est tous mis à l
est chopé nice tu peut le payer
environ 1000 euros par invité sera ni en
europe à 3000 euros par vider sa compris
en 4 200 personnes ça fait quoi deux
cent mille barrett ont arrêté durant
tiquetonne n'est pas très beau mariage
je me suis jamais marié je comprends
pourquoi
après on parle de bunge mais aussi
beaucoup de gens qui sont pas benjamin
castaldi qui cherche des sponsors et de
chaleur très bien comme ça ces navettes
en anglais mariage ouais c'est une
nouvelle tendance ou tu tu cherches
toute l'alluré exprime sa
paye plus grand chose ouais ouais là
risquent de tout bois sont tous des
retours qui autorise par exemple le
traiteur en question à distribuer ses
cartes de visite pendant là cependant la
soirée etc et de leurs cachets voilà et
du coup ça fait moi ça me choque et un
côté entreprise commerciale qui me
choque ah bah non c'est un mariage
frères de france a les moyens ils
veulent se payer un beau mariage va
pourquoi pas ça peut être mais je veux
dire à lula sont différentes de voir les
choses alors mariage voilà qui sont
sponsorisées généralement ils ont ils
ont des sous marins vous aviez des sous
à l'époque pour le faire mais vous avez
eu raison de le faire bah ouais je lui
ai alors j'ai fait pour une heureuse et
que comme l'étaient vraiment traqué par
tout le monde ressent l on va faire une
séance folle ou claire et nette qu'il
n'y a pas de problème on n'était pas du
tout
germain se souvient pas parce qu'il
était à l'intérieur du mariage lit mais
nous les aurions m quand on voit là et
que nous nous réalité quand on est
arrivé au fameux château où avait lieu
le mariage de castaldi avec château de
grosses et voilà ces stocks de gros
signes de grossesse et où ça doit cesser
dans les yvelines voilà vraiment la
morena mais il y avait les gendarmes qui
balisait la route il y avait des gens
sur les bords de la
wii on va percevoir des fourmis volantes
s'étaient donné le mot en disant qu'il y
avait plein de vedettes qui venait et
benjamin était une immense vedette mais
j'ai toujours dit qu'il y avait des gens
des gens vraiment qu'ils étaient sortant
de la route
non mais vraiment
faite par l'agencé bêta non mais des
grandes vedettes mais on avait 4 km et
90 gardes de sécurité non c'était un
truc c'est incroyable je pleurais dans
les arbres dans ce qui semble être
la plus grande vedette y avait une
grande fenêtre bastide un jardin
non non et non via veille avaient tous
des stars du rire chanter est ce qu'il
ya des gens très connus en australie ce
pôle qui a chanté chouette ah ouais
[Musique]
calme toi c'est qu'il cache en son nom
mais ce qui est comique et chanter il ya
moyen moi aussi mes chansons vous vous
avez chanté bah écoutez en tout cas
c'était pas mal c'est pas champions pas
si oui alors ça c'est ces deux titres
sur lequel je vais rencontrer faible et
ça voilà exactement ouais c'est sûr
il y aura la chance on l'aurait plus
fiable le plus simple et on va s'aimer
mais pas loin
on va s'aimer
eh ouais
[Rires]
non mais non mais suffisamment pour
viser un fils magnétique et j'adore
d'ailleurs que six mois je serai
toujours là pour aider votre fille ah
bah alors peut-être qu'il arrêtait ses
deux battants idée il chante bien situer
majesté j'ai vu j'ai adoré sonia non
mais on s'en fout 28 16 ans il est
blindé arrêté joue avec silence on vous
a mis de côté sa 60 70 arrêts tapote
acheté deux boucles d'oreilles en disant
toi et tarama goz sur la toile c'est la
brink's à gauche olympien la cagoule la
prime chez elle à la place de
falla deux salaires rtl mais
écoute fin d'année dans le challenge et
500 fortunes de
c'est pas vous qui payez l'ehpad c'est
ça arrêtez arrêtez n'essayez pas
s'appeler on sait très bien mais
isabelle si je suis fier de vous devez
très bien réussi bravo
il dit si j'étais vous je ne chauffera
plus de cadeaux aux autres chroniques
chéri samedi soir jean luc mélenchon
invité politique de léa salamé laurent
ruquier dans leur émission on est en
direct et c'est vrai que sur les réseaux
on a plein de gens qui ont dit que léa
salamé était très remonté contre jean
luc mélenchon ou vous a fait un petit
récap moi perso c'est vrai que je la
trouve bien meilleur léa salamé nation
on est on dirait je trouve que c'est la
meilleure émission qu'elle fait depuis
le début et je trouve qu'elle a elle y
trouve beaucoup plus tard car j'aimerais
que vous avez remarqué
mais parce que je la connais bien les
halles étaient avec nous
sur ces 8 à l'époque on la croit
doucement et c'est vrai que dans la vie
elle est très dark à un égo ah oui très
dark a dans la vie valérie c'est mon
grand c'est vrai beaucoup très
sympathique dans la ville très
sympathique elle est la personne qu'il
essayait de ce cadre et qu'en tant que
journaliste s imposer un paysage et la
mongie la retrouver maintenant elle
voilà exactement là on courir
si vous étiez en boîte de nuit samedi
soir à faire les fouilles sur les démons
de minuit sachez que vous avez passé une
meilleure soirée que jean luc mélenchon
qui s'est fait déglinguer sur le plateau
de on est en direct c'est la troisième
fois vous êtes candidat à la
présidentielle vous dit pas un moment
d'accès pour quelqu'un d'autre waouh bon
on avait pris l'habitude de voir léa
salamé rentré dans l'ordre les invités
vous êtes sérieux du coup jean luc
mélenchon pas bête il s'est dit qu'il
allait passer direct la pommade pour
parce qu'un trop déchiré je veux
apprécie beaucoup j'ai pas de conflit
avec vous un mais bon visiblement basse
a pas suffi pour jean-luc la gauche va
mal vous avez blessé beaucoup dans art
expo france 2 non non non vous allez on
va pas régler nos comptes et oui c'est
fait rentrer dedans malgré une bonne
répartie le jour où vous aurez une
émission qui fait autant de boîtes
noires aux élections vous viendrez me
démentir et les internautes étaient
choqués par ce spectacle est ce que léa
salamé a déjà laissé quelqu'un finir une
phrase avant de le couper avec des
questions ridicule bref le boson lui qui
était pourtant prêt à pécho samedi je
suis un homme comme tout le monde je
sais mais je sait caresser c'est pas le
sujet et j'en connais un qui aurait
mieux fait d'aller en boîte
[Musique]
j'ai accepté de faire l'émission la
semaine prochaine à
avec léa salamé et laurent ruquier voilà
c'est la seule émission parce que je
sais faire des matinales radio pour le
livre demain d'ailleurs je serai demain
matin sur rtl
17h40 avec le temps je serai avec
apolline de malherbe sur eure
lalala sur bfm rmc la balade en deux
jours et je serai donc avec laurent
ruquier samedi soir en grec avec les
deux et je les fais parce que j'ai
regardé l'émission la vérité voilà j'ai
longuement hésité j'ai trouvé les ae
l'auront je les ai trouvé sympathique
donc génie écoutez je le fais ce sera la
shoah démission que le ferait en tout
cas voilà mais en tout cas voilà j'ai
accepté de faire l'émission
c'est parce que vous aimez un mail et
binôme fonctionne très très bien au
début de l'année on a tous un plan c
bouche et le nez mais moi je trouve que
ça marche du feu de dieu bon c'est vrai
que j'ai gély et j'ai vu je trouve que
sont complètement complémentaires ça
marche très bien l aile et d'estelle et
détendue elle est pugnace elle est
solaire à la l'humour trop quelle elle
est vraiment excellente et autant
mélenchon a été très très fort contre
zemmour autant là pas pardon mais il a
été atomisée par les deux voilà
l'origine n'est pas d'arrêter très bien
il a pas plus parlé il a été atomisée
péter par laisser parler parce qu'il est
bon non moi j'ai eu l'impression
franchement y'a la cspî et jean luc
mélenchon par rancoeur rancune vengeance
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas venus débat
entre eric zemmour sur le service public
elle lui a répété lui a martelé c'est
bien qu'elle me dit mais oui mais
c'était trop pour moi c'était tellement
agressif que ça dépassait les bras il a
à peine pu parler
c'est la jci 11 et yvonne et jean luc
mélenchon c'est un tribun c'est pas une
petite chose fragile
le petit choisit maintenant qu'il est en
crise il sait
je pense même qu'il est meilleur quand
on lui rentrer dedans j'en ai quand même
ils sont là oui quand on y va et que
c'est un combat de boxe donc je pense
pas que ça lui déstabiliser plus que ça
qu'elle eût dit qu'elle lui ait dit
n'être pas venu vous m'avez plantes etc
j'ai vu le premier dire que dans le btp
on a cassé des formes qu effectivement
une façon de s'adresser aux politiques
et la cause des différends tous dit que
le couple parole n'est pas très cohérent
non mais t'es pas parler les gens moi
non
entre les deux il ya des fois où j'ai
quelques coupes trop la parole il ya des
fausses ou que sais pas c'est
complémentaire entre les deux et là j'ai
trouvé en revanche que face à mélenchon
était parfaitement dans son rôle voilà
la région voilà moi en tout cas je vous
dis sur les réseaux elle s'est fait un
petit peu bousculé comme nous tous un
rayon sur les réseaux souvent et puis
dès lors aux tic a passé un petit coup
de gueule contre un jean luc mélenchon
ça fait très long mais très bien mais à
ce point le bien des gens pourquoi bon
sens vous n'arrivez pas à vous mettre à
autour d'une table et à avoir un
programme commun il faudra lâcher
peut-être du lest dans votre programme
et les autres si mais si on veut bien
des gens on et son ego pas seulement de
votre les autres si moi je fais pas une
affaire d'ego oui mais les hivers longs
mais chacun ses 4es gosses ou un
mouchoir et vouloir le bien des gens
c'est s'entendre entre 4 5 personnes
intelligentes c'est pas rester chacun
dans son coin autrement jamais vous me
ferez croire que vous voulez le bien des
gens monsieur mélenchon si vraiment vous
pensez aux gens alors faut vous entendre
avec tous les autres ça c'est le cri que
j'avais envie de vous pousser ce soir
alors non mais il ya cette espèce d'idée
débiles qui fait que quand on est sur le
service public on n'a pas le droit
d'avoir d'avis parce que simplement de
son avis les gosses à schoder josh me
faire laurent comme ça il est vrai que
peu importe il a toujours été de gauche
j'ai voté ségolène royal moi j'aime les
gens qui ont un avis bilsen ac on peut
débattre absolue les gens neutres sous
prétexte qu'ils sont avec de l'argent
qui nous appartient se méfier voulez que
je vous dise l'adage été avec un pote la
sq reviennent et on était en train de
parler des mecs qui avaient des délais
des nox ou pas dans le bref eh ben on
discute avec vous non bah oui je peux
vous savez vous mars et moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est vrai qu'on dise et laurent
ruquier il est franchement parce qu'on
n'aime pas mille îles et rivages suis la
seule réponse tabac il a un mental
laurent il a été attaqué des milliers de
points sur son émission le samedi soir
on n'est pas couché il en a pris plein
la gueule y revient toujours il revient
il à effet la quotidienne il a marché la
presse a marché il l'a refaite il a il a
un mental de fouet à ce qu'on dit c'est
que c'est vrai que pour être animateur
comme ça ce niveau là où il faut un
mental de dengue et on disait on a très
peu qui ont un très très gros mental il
d'en avoir trop cadré soudure que c'est
vrai et laurent ont fait partie il a des
convictions il est pas géométriques
mariam et ça c'est très bien là après
toi si tu aimes ou tu aimes pas et au
moins le mérite un spectacle est garanti
la dévotion après j'ai voté de
maquereaux et puis voilà du jeu et puis
voilà je vous le dis parce que c'est une
interview politique donc je veux pas
qu'on imagine que je puisse passer par
la bande et puis non mais je vais
rejouer en rien la demande est là il le
dit cash après on est d'accord on aime
attaquer autonomous et hidalgo bombe
alors on est honnête - d'abord une
passion malheureuse au vote hidalgo les
élections oui même quand elles se
présentent pas chipoter